guys it's it's made to real me I'm back
where have you been this whole time we
going missing the door the duplicates
it's all because of him hello Chum
[Music]
you weren't planning on doing another
Power Rangers top five were you real
time to come back home to the Dino
dimension by 90s obsessed adversary I'm
never going back there
never again wrong answer
Papa spank
[Music]
number five the Phantom phenomenon a
strange spaceship arrives on earth and
is discovered by Justin's friends Niko
while at the same time mysterious
happenings start to present themselves
in angel Grove it is discovered that the
ship belongs to the Phantom Ranger a
figure clad all in black with the power
of invisibility whose true allegiance is
not known but divatox decides to strike
first and sends her forces to destroy
his ship and take him out this episode
introduced us to the Phantom Ranger and
set up a mystery surrounding his
identity that was actually never solved
while he's all build up and no payoff
our first glimpse at him offers a pretty
decent episode for turbo and honestly
anything that broke up the monotony on
the show was very appreciated the
Phantom Ranger was an indication that
some interesting stories could be
launched from this season but am I the
only one who found Cassie's infatuation
with him weird she doesn't even know
what the Phantom Ranger is and falls for
him before he even really speaks I just
can't get over how beautiful everything
looks at me it's bright its colorful so
you know I mean dare I say it there's a
sense of look'd are here oh good well
that means you can help us without
incredibly urgent matter Hey anything
that threats this threatens me good I
didn't want to have to cut off your
balls and feed them to my wildebeest it
sounds like you did I did but I won't as
partners number four wait and see
at her ballet auditions cat is shamed
into thinking she's overweight by a
fellow ballerina she soon begins an
unhealthy habit of not eating to get
into better shape for her upcoming show
to play off her body image issues
divatox ends the monster number to make
her light as a feather the other Rangers
soon realized number can also add weight
and he mobilizes some of the team cat
then has to find a way to break the
spell and help her team out of their
heavy situation so Power Rangers tried a
message episode about anorexia
and it's actually not that bad who'da
thunk it throw in a little black swan
and a really fun villain and you end up
with one of the best episodes this
season of course this is nothing too
serious they didn't have the cast or an
expert talked to the kids watching after
the credits or anything but it sends out
a positive message and I give them
credit for that I think number is one of
my favorite Power Ranger villains too
besides adding and subtracting weights
he throws giant exploding numbers and
has the best puns so this episode is a
rare victory for turbo from several
aspects of the story and characters wish
we had more like this one number three
passing the torch parts 1 & 2 divatox
his mother urges her to remove the
leader of the Power Rangers and the rest
will fall she kidnaps Tommy and plans on
sending him into the vortex of eternal
doom and sorrow but he is saved by
altruistic newcomers TJ and Cassie Tommy
and the rest of the Rangers then must
defeat flame ight before he burns down
angel Grove this was the final
appearance for some of the
longest-running Rangers we find out in
part 2 that Tommy
Adam Kat and Tanya are on their final
mission and must transfer their powers
to worthy replacements this episode
represented a big change in not only
turbo but Power Rangers history the main
cast with the exception of Justin are
all switched out in a sort of bizarre
midseason shift behind the scenes Jason
David Frank wanted to leave the show
after Zeo but was convinced to stick
around for about half of the following
season the producers later decided to
just replace four of the five Rangers
altogether and go with a fresh new cast
it took a while but eventually the new
team of TJ Cassie Carlos Ashley and
later Andros formed one of the most
memorable Power Ranger teams to date I
will admit that even though it's a
two-parter
this episode does feel rushed all of a
sudden there's an hourglass with fruit
loops in it that's supposed to signify
when the current Rangers are to turn
over their powers this was never
mentioned before and there was zero
buildup sort of strange when you
consider we have seen some very well
done Ranger exits before this
while this two-parter is definitely not
perfect there are stakes to be invested
in here it also showed that the
producers weren't quite ready to give up
on the series despite losing its cast
good thing they kept going otherwise we
never would have gotten in space oh you
got your little punk no
ah crap number two the Falls of phantom
and clash to the Megazords this
two-parter begins with a plan by divatox
to steal the phantom rangers power ruby
her plan is to use it as a power source
to activate the recently stolen turbo
Megazord but first her brother general
havoc uses his souped-up evil Zord
metallo Saurus to attack angel Grove and
hold the fading phantom Ranger as baits
their plan works as the power Ruby
successfully activates the stolen turbo
Megazord
while it's piloted by the monster cross
patch the rangers have to use their new
rescue Megazord to fight their own
twisted vehicles in a battle for the
earth this is another phantom ranger set
of episodes and they prove that when he
was involved the show tried to be a
little more serious the quality of most
of the episodes he's in speaks for
itself using his power Ruby to operate
the turbo Megazord for divatox was
pretty clever and it resulted in one of
my favorite Megazord fights this show
has ever produced the backdrop looks
great as the Sun sets and this is prime
Zord fighting right here the thing that
makes it stick out the most is TJ
battling the monster on the turbo
Megazord itself he tries to take back
control of it for the Rangers and it
results in a unique and thrilling
sequence for this show this act also
helped legitimize TJ as a courageous
leader chances are you forgotten about
these episodes but if you ever want to
check out the best of turbo or an
awesome Megazord fight seek these out
[Music]
you're an abomination you think
combining your little Power Rangers
with an 80s icon like The Terminator is
gonna be able to take home yes
[Music]
and the number one best episode of Power
Rangers turbo is chase into space parts
one and two in this finale of Power
Rangers turbo Zordon reaches out to the
Rangers and informs them that his planet
el Tarr is at war with evil forces
meanwhile demote ox is hired the
universe's toughest monster Gold Goyle
to finally destroy the turbo Rangers
while they defeat their toughest
challenge yet
both Megazords are destroyed in the
process to make matters worse the metria
and the blue Centurion leave Earth to
help Zord on a knelt are just as divatox
attacks the Power Chamber with
overwhelming numbers chasing the space
feels like a totally different show the
music is different the vibe is different
the characters seem to be written much
better things are taken way more
seriously and the stakes have never been
higher in the show's history the Power
Chamber is breached and destroyed
towards the beginning of the second
episode the Rangers have a great battle
in there with divatox his army and it
ends with their powers gone and not
knowing what to do next the command
center had been destroyed before but
this felt final divatox is called away
and is set up for the next season so all
were left with is powerless Rangers and
a blown-up base it was all leading to a
fantastic cliffhanger that got rid of
Justin as a ranger and sent the rest of
the team into space to help sort on on
LTR is it fitting that the best episodes
of Power Rangers turbo are the last ones
yeah kind of turbo was a pretty big
letdown with flashes of good stuff in it
little did we know at the beginning of
the season how fantastic the finale
would be but they very different cast
you haven't won this is only the
beginning there are more of us coming
many more when he decides to stop toying
with you the master will emerge the real
diner
he's on his way
[Laughter]
[Applause]
did you get him no he'll be back well
now that you're back not five has its
real host again are you guys covering
for me yeah it was actually a lot of fun
though maybe a little too much fun
anyway it's all yours pal
heatherann await a lot of stuff is gonna
be changing around here and I'll explain
that later but what if you guys stay on
and help me host the show you know like
the old days
[Music]
yes really okay okay okay okay okay
you